(en anglais)
Sa c e e e est aménagée,
sa marraine est prête.
Il ne manque plus qu'elle.
Celle que Bessmomomomore
espère avec impatience,
c'est Farzana Adell Ghadiya.
♪ ♪ ♪
Farzana est une Afghane qui
milite pour le droit des femmes.
Elle est issue d'une minorité
culturelle et religieuse.
"Farzana est extraordinaire,
tenace et forte", dit-elle.
Depueseseseses talibans ont
repris le pouvoir en Afghanistan
en août 2021, Farzana se cache
dans un pays qu'on ne peut
nommer pour des raisonsécécécéc.
Retourner chez elle
est hors de question.
"Les talibans ont tué
de nombreuses autres militantes.
Ils me tueraient aussi",
croit-elle.
Son espoir : trouver refuge
au Canada. Mais le processus
d'application est un parcours
du combattant.
(sonnette)
Et Farzana ne se bat pas seule.
- Nice to see you!
- Nice to see you too!
- Bessa Whitmore et un groupedea
se sont donnés pour mission
de la faire venir au Canada.
- Je l'aime comme ma propre
fille. C'est très important
pour moi et pour tous nous,
qu'elle arrive ici,,,,,,
qu'elle puisse continuer
son travail comme militante
des droits des femmes.
- À ce jour, chacune de
leur tentative s'est soldée
par un échec.
(musique grave)mememememememencé
d'appliquer au programme
humanitaire pour lesorororororos
à l'extérieur de l'Afghanistan.
Farzana répondait à tous les
critères, à l'exception d'un
seul : elle ne peut pas obtenir
une référence de l'Agence des
Nations unies pour les réfugiés;
l'organisation n'a pas de bureau
dans le pays où elle se cache.
"Pourquoi exiger d'un réfugié
qui demande l'asile de trouver
quelqu'un qui pourra confirmer
qu'il est un réfugié.
Le Canada peut effectuer
ces vérifications."
Puis, une demande de permis
de séjour temporaire pour motif
de protection lui est refusée,
puisque les fonctionnaires
y ont vu une demande
de visa de visiteur.
"J'ai trouvé ça difficile.
J'étais vraiment déçue,
spécialement venant du Canada."
SHAREN CRAIG
- J'avais honte comme Canadienne
que notre gouvernement
peut traiter une femme
comme Farzana comme ça.
C'est vraiment pas juste.
- Sans parler du cas spécifique
de Farzana, le ministre
de l'Immigration Sean Fraser
répond que les demandeurs
doivent suivre le processus
mis en place pour identifier
les personnes vulnérables.
"Le système n'est pas fait
pour que je trie sur le volet
les cas individuels portés
à mon attention."
Chris Alexander a été
ambassadeur du Canada
en Afghanistan et
ministre de l'Immigration.
Selon lui, le gouvernement
ne fait pas honneur
à sa réputation de défenseur
des réfugiés et des femmes;
il manque de volonté politique.
CHRIS ALEXANDER, ex-ambassad. du
Canada en Afghanistan, ex-min.
de l'Immig.
- On peut agir sur des questions
de principe pour protéger
ceux et celles qui défendent
les droits de la personne,
les droit des femmes
en Afghanistan.
On devrait le faire.
- Sur les 40 000 Afghans
vulnérables que le Canada
a promis d'accueillir,
près de 23 000 d'entre eux
ont foulé le sol canadien
depuis août 2021.
"Il y a des avions remplis
d'Ukrainiens qui arrivent
au Canada, et c'est tant mieux!
Leur situation est horrible,
mais si en l'espace de semaines
nous pouvons faire venir
des avions plein d'Ukrainiens
au pays, nous pouvons faire
la même chose pour les Afghans."
Pour Farzana, l'espoir réside
maintenant dans un nouveau
programme de parrainage
de réfugiés afghans
lancé à la mi-octobre.
Le temps file. Son visa dans
le pays où elle se cache expire
en janvier. Elle court le risque
d'être déportée en Afghanistan.
"Nous n'avons pas cinq, six ou
huit mois devant nous, dit-il.
Farzana n'a que deux mois.
Nous devons mettre le paquet
pour s'assurer que le
gouvernement ouvre son dossier,
qu'il l'étudie, l'approuve
et la fasse venir ici.
♪ ♪ ♪
Sa chambre l'atten